he is just as terrific as they come in
terms of his current role as a game-day
analyst as he has done since 2008 he's
my buddy Desmond Howard Howard it does
Oh doing well how about you I appreciate
you calling in I know you flew back from
Los Angeles you're you're jet-lagged and
what-have-you so I you know I love you
for it but that's just one of the many
things I love you for so first things
first I wanna stroll down memory lane
with you now
the Rose Bowl I covered was the Rose
Bowl that Bo Schembechler played a coach
for the last time for Michigan and I
remember you got out there towards the
end a little bit and and mix things up
and did well did what was it like being
around Bo's final days yes oh man you
talking about you talking about going
back I mean first of all I am it was a
truly rich and just an honor I was
honored to play for Coach him back I was
blessed really blessing me obviously
back then I mean he was he was as as big
as it gets in college football and to be
able to place for him and playing his
last game his last season man was just
tremendous for me obviously as a
youngster you you really don't
understand the impact that it's gonna
have on your life or even the meaning of
it at that point because you're still
trying to figure life out but you
understand how specialist this person is
especially idea because that was you
know a large part of why I actually went
to University of Michigan to play
football
so man just one of those things that is
something I can tell like my sons and
you know other people sit around you go
talking to guys who actually love
college football like my coworker Kirk
you know having conversations with
people like that like they get it and
it's just another thing that makes me
realize just how blessed I've been you
know to me though of course I do and I
was sitting in the press box that day
covering it for getting for the Michigan
daily and the two things I remember is
that Bo mr. three yards and a cloud of
dust against USC just a few minutes left
in his illustrious coaching career
pulled and called a fake punt
worked about got called back for holding
and he got so ballistic you tacked on 15
yards for unsportsmanlike conduct
because he threw his headset down so
hard he went as almost when ass over
teakettle does yeah I'm it that was that
wasn't holding though I mean the second
thing I remember is that USC had a
number 55 on their side of the field I
thought there was two of them because he
was everywhere and it was junior sale
yeah yeah special player you right I
mean I just will never forget that and
then just just the Rose Bowl in itself
what do you take out of the 2020 Rose
Bowl and Justin Herbert's performance
against Wisconsin what do you take out
of that game does you know six plus five
six or six quarterbacks who want to sit
out there and act like this Jalen Hurst
now get out here and he's bowl games I
always want to start carrying the ball
all of a sudden I mean not what I
expected from Jay from Justin Herbert
you know I did think that coming to this
game rich that Justin would really want
to try to put on some sort of
performance I was like you know this guy
was a player who a year ago I actually
thought was gonna come out and be the
top receiver
I'm sorry quarterback picking and drab
right and you know he decided to come
back to Oregon or he wanted to win a you
know a pac-12 championship get an
opportunity to maybe playing the college
football playoff and win a national
championship
okay I respect that and I always loved
his arm like I think he can make all the
throws you know he tries to he has a
tremendous amount of confidence in his
arm and so this means he would try to
squeeze that ball into the smallest or
tightest of windows tighter tighter
spaces because he he has just that type
of confidence and it showed it in a lot
of games and so I I thought that he was
going to come out and really try to
impress and in the Rose Bowl cuz he had
some ups he had some downs here there's
on the stink game and in rich I was
talking to a couple
guys and they said that they thought
that the Arizona State game because
their you know their coaching staff is
littered with NFL guys you got her Matt
where she got Marv Lewis you got other
guys they brought in two assistant
coaches who don't have the names that
these guys had on that staff but they
came up with some NFL type concepts
defensively and they thought that's what
really affected Justin Herbert the night
that they ended up pulling off you know
one of the biggest upsets in the pac-12
this year and ASU beat the Oregon Ducks
and so I wanted to see okay this guy's
going to have an opportunity now to go
up against this guy who's Jim Leonard
the defensive coordinator for Wisconsin
who also has an NFL background know well
okay this is like his opportunity now to
show the you know he you know that was
not indicative of the type of
quarterback he is that he's grown from
that that night he's learned you know
he's not gonna let these d C's you know
fooled him don't just try to air it out
I had absolutely no idea this man will
go out there and you know turn to like a
Jalen Hertz owner so one of these guys
who's a mobile quarterback - I knew he
was a clinic I mean even a year ago I
did a tape on him and I forget who the
opponent was but he was like I remember
him being like a long Strider and you
can see how guys they we know once he
got out if he got in front of certain
guys they couldn't make up the ground on
like man's guys here decent speech was a
long Strider
but man he just you know went out there
and I thought he showed that he was
willing to do whatever it took for his
team to win that rose but which is which
is pretty pretty special to Desmond
Howard here on the Rich Eisen show yeah
I mean we're seeing Josh Allen for the
bills on ESPN on Saturday afternoon in a
playoff game I mean he's he's he's
running all over the place now that he's
gotten to the NFL and we saw as you
pointed out Trevor Lawrence run away
from Ohio State in the Fiesta Bowl and
Joe burrow playing out of his skull
right now so how do you see the national
championship game playing out while
on the phone that day what I'm so
excited about this one oh man it just
seems like okay let me let me couch this
by telling you I don't I'm not a guy who
gets on television trying to make like
these big statements like trying to make
these big grandiose statements they're
like headlines you know I I try to stay
away from their stuff but I really can't
rich I really can't remember the last
time I saw an office that execute as
such a high level on such a consistent
basis like when you watch Joe Burrell
and not only Joe either yeah look at
these receivers that he has at his
disposal to but when you watch them the
first thing is like me this guy just
doesn't miss like he just doesn't miss
all these throws I mean you look at the
championship game I'm sorry you look at
the Fiesta Bowl another semifinal
semi-final game
well house they played Clemson and you
see mr. Rose here you see drug boss here
I mean one of the things I tell people
you know who talking about you know JK
Dobbins like with JK DOM is like drop
two touchdowns like two obvious
touchdown we look at unless you like Joe
doesn't miss throws and his receivers
and running backs they don't drop ball I
mean it's just such a high level on a
consistent basis we can't we got it
doesn't matter who the opponent is so I
want to see now how Brent Venables who
an FBS turbo Clemson's DC I mean he
threw everything but the kitchen sink at
Justin fields and Ohio State's office I
want to see like you know is he gonna
you know and I don't feel that's kind of
disrespectful like if a defensive
coordinator like just starts blitzing
and bringing pressure kind of
disrespectful to the office I want to
see if he disrespects LSU's office in
the same manner in which he did Ohio
State's office because they got just so
many weapons this is you got Justin
Jefferson who had a record in the Peach
Bowl against Oklahoma at four touchdowns
in the first half you got um he had just
got Jamar chase whose
Biletnikoff Award winner which is given
to the best receiver in the country
she got class it was a lair who's like
the most important person on that office
whose name is not Joe Burrell
he's a Swiss Army knife knife as a
running back and then you got Thaddeus
Moss Randy mosses and the tight end is
Mawson people tied in so many weapons
all over the field I mean that chess
match is going to be interesting to
watch rich and I can't wait for it
Desmond our here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you think ii was going to say
monday i we're going to the NFL we've
given alabama as much as we could give
them as much as we can we don't have
much anything else to give them for free
you know so i i'm but he's a different
cat like if you if you listen to to
listen to his interviews and the way he
operates and the way he thinks he's such
a different cat it would not surprise me
to hear him you know say he's returning
to Tuscaloosa especially when you start
listening some of the guys who who said
they're they're coming back next year
for for Alabama like I could see these
guys sit around talking to each other
and coming up with some sort of playing
world yeah you coming back okay no I'm
gonna come back to gonna shock the world
something of that magnitude I'm thinking
he should go ahead and take his talents
to the NFL oh and I fully great Desmond
I mean because again you want a
championship with Favre look how he came
into the league Aaron Rodgers followed
up Favre
look how he came in the league T b12
look how he came into the league mahomes
let's see we could go with the current
presumptive MVP of the league and in
Lamar Jackson look how not getting
drafted in the top ten worked out for
him I mean we could go up and down in
sideways to to point this stuff out but
again I'm not number thirteen in Alabama
Crimson Tide and you say he's a
different cat so to me you know he makes
no money zero dollars you that the coach
does Aflac commercials he can't
yes so that's I'm in full agreement with
you right there let me just talk about
the if you will elephant in the maze and
Blue Room here does I came on the show
starting to say that our guy coach
Harbaugh has to find and maybe there is
that kid currently there right now at
quarterback with the ultimate of respect
and thanks to Shay Patterson for his two
years of service some above-average
consistent play that keeps the defense
off the field a little bit more and uses
a lot of these stud wide receivers who
are big and physical that Harbaugh has
brought to campus what say you
does yeah yeah I think that he's he just
he hasn't been able to hit on a
quarterback in you know we started this
whole interview off talking about a
quarterback who's an impactful player
and if you look at the college football
playoff you know each team has a
quarterback that's an impactful plan we
started talking about Justin Harbor
Justin Herbert obviously has next-level
talent but then on top of that you know
he showed his athletic ability running
the ball to Trevor Lawrence a week ago
in the Fiesta Bowl another guy with
next-level challenges obviously clear we
do we've known that since he came on
high school but then here he is running
the ball so my point is you gotta have
someone out there that's really really
considered a difference maker and since
he's been in Ann Arbor he hasn't been
able to put that guy out there on the
field that's the difference maker you
know a lot people talked about Dylan
McCaffrey and he's a guy who people in
the program they love but unfortunately
rich he's he's one of those guys who he
just can't stay healthy you know he
cannot stay healthy when you see him
he's like I don't maybe six to six for
have no idea exactly how Toby he's a
tall quarterback when you watch him on
the field he's definitely athletic like
you can tell he got the gene I mean he
can run with the ball and he's in there
easy very accurate but he can't stay
healthy he you know so in that I guess
in that regard he's
snake-bitten but yeah Gemma has to find
a difference-maker at the quarterback
position and a couple of spots too you
know he has four wide receivers who are
big guys he doesn't have like a Jonathan
Taylor or JK diamonds or running back at
this point who has proven that he's a
guy who you have to game plan against
like a guy who you say this guy can take
you to distance every time he touches
the ball we need to be you know we have
to have someone who's a whose accounting
for him and every moment he's on the
feel like he to me he hasn't put that
sort of guy out there offensively either
so it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens moving forward yeah I'm with he
does and in terms of running backs man
there's some Dobbins is terrific I know
you mentioned he dropped a couple he's
terrific
etienne oh my god in other words Edwards
a layer and Jonathan Taylor I mean I I
definitely feel for the 28 to 30 year
old free agent you're seeing it you're
seeing it here in and year out that's
the best receiver that's coming to the
next level last one for you that you've
seen I don't know who's declared yet
right you do you got some underclassmen
who can't come well they can come back
like you know we all expected Gerry
Judy's a guy here unless you declare it
today when I was flying back from LA
like but going to the game I was I
wanted him to declare during the second
quarter yesterday desmond taken into
2020 dress - thanks for the call
appreciate the time get some rest
love watching you on TV but you might
thanks rich I appreciate you a tee time
anytime
I love doing the show with you anytime
I'm a thanks Desmond you take all three
yeah last one for you oh my gosh I
should ask you would you vote for the
Heisman outside who would you vote for
for the Heisman Oh
Joe Joe's
music the number one vote getter for me
he was in the number one position yes he
was I thought Joe him he's been
outstanding and it's just from top to
bottom from beginning to end
take care of yourself test of the time
Desmond Howard on on both on Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app